[Musique]
ne changera jamais être
à mi temps la classe e voie avant dix
pas trop tard une vie à deux c'est non
enfin robert ce n'est pas manqué dix ans
mais si paula mais si c'est comme je te
jure de cambrai c'est pas comme ça que
ça s'est passé
mon petit mon compte steam et tu as
oublié tout simplement moi moi c'est
l'expérience que tu pourras pas pour
l'expérience flamand est très fort il y
en a à revendre taisez-vous gamin j'ai
tout simplement c'est vous qui allez
fêter vos femmes bien sûr au garrot ce
n'est pas l'entente lui peu de la fin
d'un soir de la victoire
laisse-moi bouleversé aux larmes la
tuque ont autre chose au nom auprès du
bij qui se fera pas de mal je veux bien
sa vie birot du n'importe quoi il ne
faut pas lui en vouloir
et toi tu m'en veux pas pourquoi il n'y
a pas de rêve
un petit leur attention ce qui va ce
prix là
mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs vous
devez vous poser une question que faites
vous des d12 de coûts de 2008
non c'est et était une réalité
vous ne comprenez pas les amis mes amis
savoir vivre ces savoirs beau rassurez
vous car je compte lui déjà au plus haut
je conclus donc que l'énigme jojo doit
être examinée sérieusement et en
attendant je bois sa solution au conflit
de générations toutefois pas pas de sens
dès noël
vous ne voyez pas ce petit matin à
minuit
aussi j'ai trouvé on débouche traction
pen y compris moi je suis d'accord et
que tu te tu as compris et pas la messe
de vie à toi la prime time
tu es la plus intelligente dont jeanne
ouvre helmand un peu froid la messe est
le pauvre petit mois pourquoi parce que
je crois que reçoit paris gros porc je
ne compose à les voir
je suis d'accord mais une condition
formelle laquelle vous connaissez la
chapelle des sabines fait d'aller dire à
moi je la connais elle est ravie ce chai
trop loin mais lens à 35 minutes en face
en miles ou hébergées à minuit apporte
des agneaux bon alors entendu rendez
vous culture la place et on revient en
caravane philippe pour le réveillon
d'accord bon ben si on devait les coups
d'état sur mon compte
d'accord on attendant minuit ce que tu
acceptes de dîner avec moi je t'invite
aujourd'hui aller en ski jusqu'au savine
ba prenait la piste verte
à oui mais vous habitez walker au caire
ah oui les gens me dis mais c'est toi
qui lis ça n'est pas moi c'est parce que
ça exactement mais j'ai compris j'ai
même très bien compris qui cherchent
tous les préfixes mois débat dax tu
crois que j'espère le voir la vérité je
me demande comment j'ai pu me tromper
ascquois oui à ton sujet moi non plus je
crois que je ne peux pas avoir tout
allait bien on se trouve à minuit devant
là chacun des services parents père
robert pour l'instant gens de chez moi
soyez gentil de me chercher ton talent
oui oui ça allait d'alba et son ouïe
d'ingénieurs saab a entendu merci projet
je prends mes skis
moi c'est pas le moment mais rothen
amusant il faut dire ici nous faisant un
bout de chemin ensemble robert robert
n'est pas gentil avec contient il est
gentil avec personne ça lui vaudra
malheur il viendra aux abymes j'ai bien
peur que non
[Musique]
o o
à
oh
[Musique]
on va t'on rex
je connaissais
hamon
[Musique]
tu la totale
oh
ce qui m'arrive
[Applaudissements]
là c'est moi où suis-je
[Musique]
à
je te mets là une maison engloutie
c'est pour le site
cassel me croire
il doit expliquer ça
l'obstacle à la cause est tombé ici
là dedans
chaque clip
comment sortent au lycée
georges jacques lui cinq ans je suis là
je suis tombé ils sont passés tout près
du rhin sous six mois
c'est passé
le volet c'est fermé enfermé tu les a
enfermés sans fermer c'est un viol
je suis tombé par la cheminée dans un
chalet a englouti sous la neige
j'aurais dû m'en douter le village est
évacué
c'est trop bête et maintenant tu es en
face de toi même loin de tes amis face à
face avec toi loin des habits pour
maintenant il va quoi que ce soit chez
pour le bo j'avais d'autres choses et le
dire
que vas tu faire sans nuri coeur sont
nourriture
[Applaudissements]
chaque année par ici les villages sont
entièrement couverts par année noyés
dans la neige les propriétaires les
retrouve au printemps au printemps
la comprendre on va me délivrer
[Musique]
pas nous dit ici
nous avons cru être heureux cette joie
ne nous apprenait rien le voyage reste
ims terje un mystère vite mon dieu je ne
vais pas appris à voir ni à toucher je
voudrais pouvoir écouter encore des
chansons pour savoir si je sais entendre
tu vas mourir étouffé la cm et tout fait
sans heurts et sans espoir logique sans
un jeu blanc sans brise 100 jours et
dans ma maison morte qui ne renvoie plus
lente alors je veux pas mourir étouffé
peut pas mourir comme ça
jacqueline vous dit pas vraiment fâché
à ce moment tu m'en veulent une pause
est au rendez vous
mais tu ne sais pas que je risque de
mourir le plus bêtement qui soit
je pleure franchement infosport
l'équipe
non pas parce qu'elle tout pétrole mais
bouger
l'air
un sou j'ai plus l'air
à quoi servait à vis tu assures été joie
et de plaisir de par la peine d autres
mais tu ne connais pas le banner il que
tel
étrange et étrangers
tu ravageait les semences ne donnait pas
de moi son rejeton
je touche pourquoi pourquoi
est-ce que tu le méritais mettons-nous
notre malheur
oui je ne servait à rien je bafouille
je tenais les amano merci je me
délectais me deleu même est je me
demandais pourquoi j'existe m
[Musique]
salo dangereux ça loin
je me faisais plus raide wigan à manger
ici et là ne respirait plus
tu fais bouffer brûler salle où j'ai
mauvais bruller
de quoi je veux jouer à cause de toi d
rect
ce qui me reste
rex
[Musique]
rex où es tu
tudor rex outils le chien tu ne veux pas
que montrer de te méfies
c'est vrai que tu te mets vie
tu comprends tout sur jeudi est-ce que
tu comprends ce que je passe
il est où des mets de mourir de la
fidélité
rien ne vaut plus que là
viens ici
au toit que mon innocence exaspère je te
reconnais ne te retrouves pas tues moi
me rends dans ton visage
toi qui veux me tuer et que j'ai
toujours aimé clermont et obscurément
dans mon instinct dans mon coeur
comment suis-je la victime et comment
cessé de t'aimer
oh
[Musique]
les deux et les gestes car ils ne
commettent pas d'iniquité
celui qui détruit l'innocence n'était
pas fait pour voir le jour
[Musique]
à
c'était joyeux je laisse musée à ciel
sans nuage et je prêtais mourir de la
paix de mon âme plus tard elle est
passée au heat est beaucoup plus tard
tous les lisières mater j'avais aimé et
ma vie audacieusement l'étape et
ailleurs
je laisse les portes de neige sous un
ciel clair de miroirs à l'assaut de la
vie est encore très loin de son terme
et voilà que sonne des cloches et je ne
sais plus s'il faut sourire de mourir
[Musique]
je ne sais plus si je mets mail s res si
je mens te ra jamais une demande donc à
l'honneur
je t'aime jamais je t'aime
tous les deux j'ai voulu me rejoint
grâce à toi je sais pas c'est maintenant
je n'y a pas de toi non
mélodie du père se fait entendre toutes
ont flairé ne peut rien contre le
tombeau exxon regarde moi tes yeux
surpris beaucoup mieux
[Musique]
oh
bon
[Musique]
on
et
[Musique]
mr
il est trop tard c'est presque fini
enfin jacqueline et robert de son plein
non alors qu'est ce qu'on fait on rentre
mais non profitons-en
on va passer chéquier vous on va leur
amener croyez qu'on pourrait pas entrer
maintenant vous ça doit être joli vous
êtes sûr que jacqueline n'est pas là
elle est fâchée avec robert allons
dépêchez vous si l'on va tout raté
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouais mais qu'est ce que tu vas te
glisser je t'expliquerai je croyais
qu'il n'était pas venu si je t'attendais
tu comprends j'ai pas osé rentrer j'ai
pas osé
puis avec le chien j'avais tellement
peur qu'une seule réellement fâchée nord
si tu étais là pendant tout ce temps tu
étais là oui c'est pour toi que j'étais
là robert qu'est ce qui t'arrive
dis-le moi je t'en supplie maintenant je
ne sais plus elle je suis peut-être
digne de vivre
tu viens
[Musique]
oh
ans
à
[Musique]